[Music]
the first few levels of Super Mario run
will make any Mario fan feel right at
home with the series polished graphics
and Mario's characteristic agility
present and accounted for
the game immediately feels like a winner
and you might find that it continues to
be it all depends on your willingness to
revisit the same levels over and over
again in search of modest rewards to be
fair run is the most convenient Mario
game there is with 2d level design that
lives up to the series rock solid
reputation it's also complemented with
graphics and moves that compare
favorably to the refined new Super Mario
Brothers games on both DS and 3ds with
enhanced portability however comes a few
understandable sacrifices but run feels
like a Mario game from beginning to the
end of its adventure and the ease with
which you can make Mario jump bounce off
walls and spin attack enemies in midair
with a simple tap of the screen
feels great not limiting
rather than fight to reach the end of a
level by mastering platforming which is
the easiest it's ever been for the
series your ultimate goal is to collect
coins on your way to the finish line
familiar gold coins are aplenty but
there are other harder to reach coins in
every level that require more finesse in
strategic platforming than usual as fun
as runs levels can be they are
undoubtedly short and easy and it's not
hard to finish all of them in less than
two hours if you simply aim for the
finish line but when you choose to hunt
for specific coins rather than simply
enjoy the flow and excitement of
platforming run unfortunately loses some
of its magic that made it so gratifying
at the start replaying levels then
becomes somewhat of a grind with a small
selection of levels and their brief
nature you're never so far removed from
a stage that your next visit feels like
a trip down memory lane either
repeatedly replaying runs 1 minute or
less stages quickly grows tiresome but
when you tire of chasing coins and
replaying levels you at least aren't
left empty-handed you still have the
kingdom builder and toad rally modes to
explore with a bank full of coins you
can construct a small kingdom with
houses flowers and other flourishes
outfitting your slice of land is both
for your personal gratification and for
the populace of toads that eventually
move in but rather than attracting new
neighbors through fancy landscaping you
need to impress them during toad rally
challenges by collecting as many coins
as possible in the allotted time it's a
coin trial rather than a time trial
[Music]
[Applause]
toads come in a small variety of colors
and it's important to diversify your
town is the only way to unlock more
expensive and rare items for your
kingdom for the inherent sense of
competition and the potential rewards
tied to a successful toad rally run
these challenges become the most
enjoyable excuse to continue playing run
at all and if you manage to fill your
kingdom with toads of all colors you
will eventually unlock new playable
characters usable in both the main game
and in toad rally races Princess Peach
becomes available after completing the
game normally and she comes with the
usual ability to slowly float to the
ground after jumping Luigi Yoshi and
toadette must be earned through toad
rally however but after giving peach a
fair shake the differences between her
and Mario aren't meaningful enough to
reinvigorate old stages to seek out new
characters
[Music]
the elephant in the room is the fact
that smartphones are home to numerous
persistent and endless running games
many of which are excellent and free or
far cheaper than the $10 you have to pay
to play run beyond the third level run
is definitely one of the most polished
examples of a mobile running game but
without an option to run endlessly
through procedurally generated levels
you never get a chance to truly savor
the active platform the game's best
aspect and that's to say nothing of the
games always online requirement on one
hand it's a relief should your phone
lose a data connection in the middle of
a level you can still make it to the
finish line but run will simply not
start or allow you to continue if you
are in a dead zone or without Wi-Fi for
a game without traditional micro
transactions or open-ended online
competition this requirement is simply
baffling it's easy to fault run for
various reasons but it's still hard to
totally lose appreciation for how well
it's brought the series core gameplay to
smartphones simple controls be damned
ghrelin offers great platforming and
that distinct Mario charm that
Nintendo's perfected over the years it's
a shame to find that it's on the easy
side and bereft of a long lasting
platforming adventure but run is the
sort of game you'll be happy to have in
your pocket and a testament to the
series refined DNA
[Music]